had a random memory this morning by the
way I like the shirt thanks dude I'm
dressing up it's very Euro summer yeah I
don't know why I'd buy clothes for that
yeah weird is that shirt for something
not it could have been okay it also was
just available ah where's it from oh you
know I don't give away my secrets
super rare yeah I was gonna say super
rare find Zara is it spelled with four
letters I could have sent people on a
spiral serious
can't be h m Gap
[Laughter]
is it like is it silky can I feel it
it's [ __ ] it looks a little shimmery
yeah feel it
yeah yeah
I think it's funny that you say all this
because there was a comment from the
draft day that said hey you guys need to
start bullying Cody for his clothes what
did I wear uh I don't know some dumb
Birkenstocks oh yeah yeah they're not
dumb by the way you had like this uh
Rainforest Cafe button up wasn't that
bad anyway I was just saying bring it up
it seemed like you knew that I was gonna
come
on you today
just went neutral as hell it's all black
okay this is not that bad it's a little
like Venice hippie damn I remember your
shirt being a lot
um the shirt is better looking yeah I
know I'm wearing furry Burks with socks
on them but I bought those on a whim and
they just been sitting in my closet I'm
like I gotta wear these at some point I
didn't want to go barefoot because I
didn't want to give out the dogs for
free yeah of course so I put the socks
on yeah that's fine no yeah you look
like you uh gentrify small apartments
that's all yeah but like in a cool way
yeah in a cool way yeah I kicked out all
these people a lot of my artist friends
live here yeah and I opened a sick
coffee shop nft Gallery down the street
yeah anyway I had a random memory of
high school where I was talking to my
friends about some girls that were like
in our group hell yeah and yeah
and
privately I thought I was amongst
friends and I commented that I believed
one of our girlfriends like one of our
home girls had a mustache okay I just
instantly was like is it just me just
she got a mustache in the moment it just
seems sort of innocuous some people were
like I don't think so but people like
yeah I think she does I'm just kind of
next day I got snitched on
her two sisters confront me and go why
the [ __ ] are you saying as a mustache
first of all I pose it as a question and
I was so caught up in the moment
because we are such a tight-knit group
that I was like so now I'm busy just
like hey I wasn't I didn't mean it in
any kind of mean way it's my bad it's
just sort of like an observation and it
just hit me in the shower this morning
who [ __ ] snitched and some of those
guys I don't hang out with anymore so
I'll never know you hadn't been
wondering that since that day that's not
like the first thing that I'd wondered
on that day I just I'm just a very
straight up person so I said yeah you
know I did say something to that tune so
that's that's my bad and then I just
left it at that I didn't really care but
now it I don't know why it hit me in the
shower and you don't know you still
don't know I I don't know hmm some of
those dudes who we don't hang out with I
got a little surprise for you yeah all
right [ __ ] I brought in some of those
dudes yeah yeah and we're gonna find out
who it was that's great because I
brought my [ __ ] A Bug Assault gun
yeah and I'm pissed I thought you were
good I thought for some reason I thought
that story was gonna end like really
dark I don't know why no but as you were
saying it I would just imagine you being
like I was looking at the obituaries
today and she's dead no no no I wonder
if she still has a mustache
hmm
I don't know
you know she did it's fine
yeah that's okay I'm not gonna snitch yo
Noel said he thinks you might have a
mustard dude that reminds me of that
moment in love Island do you remember
that
when who was it it was it was uh ekansu
Tommy is telling Gemma how much she like
or he's like predicting or she he's
reading her mind that's what it was and
he's like yeah you don't like Luca very
much oh yeah yeah and she was like yeah
you're not wrong or whatever and then
Atkins who just like gets up walking oh
that and just oh okay yeah yeah it
literally must have been that and it's
so whack because I've posed it I don't
even know what prompted me to say but
it's just sort of like a does she kind
of I was like yeah and we just carried
on one of them got up from there
b-lined it over to that girl what was
the girl's name uh
David
okay got it straight over to David okay
hey David
yeah well says you have a mustache what
a [ __ ] [ __ ] it was just a teenage
boy observation you know yeah was it
mean yeah but you know it's just me
being a teenage boy just pose that
question yeah it's not like no one even
went in on her no one was like yo
mustache girl that
we didn't even do that we're just having
just a plain conversation whoever this
was clearly they wanted they wanted to
get with it do you have an idea of who
it was
why did one of our homies who like I
could see him stirring the pot give him
a call no no no no no come on no no he's
probably at work nah and and he wouldn't
even remember that's the problem is I
could see him twisting my words on
purpose hey no well so you got a big
mustache I'm just watching it blow up on
me so he would text her right after and
be like you won't believe who just
called me yeah and what he said yeah
he's still saying you have a mustache
dude I'd be pissed yeah I only got two
suspects well one is stronger than the
other the other one would be such a wild
like ain't no way then he stopped
hanging out with us because
um him and
the ironically the guy who I think told
uh oh wait no no that's my other that's
my other friend they boxed
uh and uh my friend beat the brakes off
him he was very upset he just
disappeared he actually is that it was
at my place and then after he lost he
got so angry that he lost that he
punched a big [ __ ] in like one of the
walls and then just walked out yeah took
the bus yeah and everyone was like dude
it's not that serious